Carnage Goes to Hell and kills a God and
it's amazing check this out so what this
does is this initially opens up with
hella the ruler of hell now we're going
to go into some detail about the nature
of this place a little bit later in this
video because it is important to
understand but one of the things to keep
in mind is that we don't know exactly
why Carnage is doing what he's doing
that hasn't necessarily been revealed
yet he's literally on a kind of quest to
just attain these little bits of things
here and there and so the ending of this
is going to be nuts because I'm curious
to see how you guys feel about this but
initially hella is told by one of her
priestesses that in effect Carnage along
with Kenneth Neely is on his way here
now for those of you guys who are
catching up with us you will find a link
to the Carnage playlist as a pinned
comment here in the video so make sure
you check the comments for that but the
overall gist here is that Kenneth Neely
was a guy who was trying to gain the
attention of Carnage by basically
committing a series of gruesome murders
which he ultimately did he just didn't
quite know what he was getting into when
he started making deals with Carnage as
anybody who's familiar with the
character will tell you the other part
of this is she says that John shade
along with Cletus Cassidy is on his way
here as well now Cletus Cassidy is the
traditional host of Carnage in the same
way that Eddie Brock is the traditional
host of Venom the difference is that
Carnage and Cletus Cassidy have been
separated so the Carnage symbiote's just
doing its own thing Cletus is currently
occupying the mind of John Shake meaning
he's just a personality that talks to
John right that's really all it is but
these guys are all headed towards this
realm for a particular purpose now the
funny thing about hella is she initially
decides not to intervene not to step in
she will eventually but she chooses not
to right now and this all goes into the
nature of hella right remember she's
always looking for a way to escape her
position in ruling her realm and expand
its sphere of influence out into the
other Realms it's just kind of her main
Mo and so what we end up doing is
jumping over to John Shea now again
Cletus constantly Chimes into him and
one of the things to keep in mind is
that when John shade first encountered
Carnage and when he was imbued with the
Cletus Cassidy personality this came
with a small portion of the Carnage
symbia it's not enough for him to fully
utilize the Symbiote in its totality but
it's enough to get him out of like some
hairy situations and that's literally
what happens here right like they're
just kind of coming across the various
denizens that exists within the realm of
hell some of which are beings who have
just kind of taken up residence there
because they were sent there when they
died others are just beings that have
been there the entire time but whatever
the scheme and motivation the level of
power these guys have are pretty capable
and that's what we end up finding out
the reason why John shade is here is to
cut Carnage off at the pass and get to
malachith before Carnage camp now this
is a really really cool thing because we
haven't seen malakith since the end of
the war of Realms and for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with that story
we don't need to go into detail about it
but the long and short of it is that the
war of Realms was a Thor story that
basically dealt with malachith launching
an attack against all the nine Realms
including Asgard in an effort to conquer
him but John shade realizing malekith is
what Carnage is going after is a huge
thing because if the Carnage symbiote
bonds itself to malachith it could
change everything and the reason for
this is malachith is every bit as
powerful if not more powerful depending
on the situation than someone like Thor
malakith bonded to a Carnage symbiote
would unleash chaos across the entirety
of the universe almost nobody could stop
him he's that capable and so John's
showing up here he's actually talked to
you by the Cletus Cassidy personality
and the question is how did he get here
now of course again John doesn't really
know the specifics about what went on
with malakis the war of Realms all that
kind of stuff he just knows like some
dark elves showed up on Earth in New
York and like fought the superheroes and
the superheroes one and that's basically
it and even while Cletus Cassidy doesn't
know the details the important thing
here is Cletus knows enough to know that
if Carnage gets his hands on malakis
it's game over so he literally tells
John there's only one option you have
here which is to kill him now one of the
things that I want to specify do not let
cletus's intentions here trick you into
thinking he's a good guy he's not Cletus
has never been a good guy he is a tried
and true psychopath right he's the
answer to the question what would happen
if Joker from DC Comics got the Venom
symbia that's what he was supposed to
answer when he was originally created
and he answered it in spectacular
fashion and so this is one of those
instances when Cletus just kind of shows
that he has no real Humanity or remorse
of any kind whatsoever and even John
shade chimes in and says like I'm a cop
Cletus but I can't just kill people
arbitrarily and the responsive Cletus is
you are in Hell John shade driven by a
symbiote running through your veins
while the voice of a serial killer talks
to you in your your head I think we left
cops and robbers behind quite some time
ago don't you and so following that we
basically switched back over to Carnage
and Kenneth Neely now again Kenneth is
just kind of being brought along for the
ride and where initially he was just
ecstatic about the idea of joining
Carnage the longer he's been on this
quest with the Carnage symbiote and the
more he's learned just how psychotic the
current symbiote is the more he's
realized he doesn't want to have
anything to do with this and all this
really comes to a head when he's met by
Roosevelt now Roosevelt is basically
what's referred to as the sin eater
quite literally those who arrive within
the sphere of hell and even in this
particular instance when Roosevelt
stares into their eyes they're forced to
relive all the pain and anguish that
they've instilled in people across the
world now it's not the same as the
Penance stare from the Ghost Rider right
the Ghost Rider makes you feel the
physical pain that you forced everybody
else to endure across the entirety of
the time you've been doing terrible
things what Roosevelt does is he forces
you to look back on the things that
you've done almost as if you're
observing them in the third person and
so he literally uses his power on
Kenneth and Kenneth is forced to witness
every horrific act that he had committed
now what's so interesting about this is
you could argue that it's the evolution
of Kenneth kind of moving away from
being like this Psychopathic killer you
know sociopath type person and him
becoming more human right regaining his
Humanity but the reality here is I would
argue that what's really taking place is
that in those moments when Kenneth was
committing those heinous acts there was
a kind of Separation it was one of those
things where he didn't really see them
as people they were just a means to an
end which is oftentimes the motivation
of a sociopath and a psychopath a
complete and total lack of empathy
whether they're born without it or they
simply lose it over the course of their
life it's lack of empathy nonetheless
but by Kenneth having to watch the
things that he's done suddenly he has to
come to terms with himself as a person
and that's what's so crazy here is
because in this moment he kind of breaks
on a personal level and then Roosevelt
turns attention to Carnage and this is
when things get really cool because
Carnage almost taunts it right and says
like if you want to make people relive
their sins or you want people to see
what could happen as a result of the
things that they do then look in my eyes
and see what I see and that when
Roosevelt looks into the eyes of Carnage
it in turn experiences Mass pandemonium
and Chaos right the idea that Carnage
wants to take over not just the world
but the universe itself to instill chaos
fear death suffering all that kind of
stuff right to be the literal embodiment
of Carnage itself across all of space
and time and it's enough to drive
Roosevelt insane right even so far that
it loses its eyesight right now of
course one of the things to understand
is that because of the fact that hella
kind of rules this place I wouldn't say
with an iron fist she effectively sees
all and so her Priestess watching What's
Going On Through The Eyes of Roosevelt
in turn informs hella of what this
entity has witnessed and again hella
chooses not to act she's really more
curious about what's going on here now
one of the things that I also want to
establish here is that's the level of
power hella has when it comes to these
different beings also known as hell
Lords Mephisto hella any one of these
guys they're the most powerful in their
own realm now they're not all powerful
really good example of this is Franklin
Richards the son of Reed Richards
defeated Mephisto in his own realm and
so when you're talking about beings with
this level of power for somebody like
Carnage he's no match for hella that's
just the way it is in her own realm he's
no match for her and it would be a
Fool's errand to try to kill her in the
first place at least that seems to be
the case here in the moment and so
that's why she's not overly freaked out
she's not terrified by some symbiote
that's gone awry and shown up on her
doorstep causing pandemonium and Chaos
out there in the realm somewhere and so
one of the other things that goes on
here is there is a bit of a conversation
between Carnage and Kenneth in terms of
the nature of the place that they're in
and Kenneth even asked the question like
I've had to witness everything that I've
done is this where I'm going to end up
when I die and the response of Carnage
is only if you're a viking but as
Carnage and Kenneth continually make
their way towards basically finding
malachith we end up jumping back to John
shade and finding out that he didn't
kill malachith instead he set malachith
free and here's the irony of this where
Kenneth Neely has no idea or had no idea
what he was getting into when he started
making deals with Carnage John shade has
no idea what he's getting into when he's
making deals with malachith because in
his mind the idea of malachith being
freed by John and the two of them
escaping would be something malachith
would be thankful for and to a degree he
is but with thanks also comes a kind of
Unwritten rule which is to say I've set
you free we need to get out of here and
whether malekith agrees with it or not
he would basically honor that one
request right it's just how we do things
just the way things are and so what ends
up happening is malachith and John shade
arrive at a place whose name I can't
pronounce but it's basically called The
Cosmic Waterway now one of the funny
things about this is that this is one of
many instances of people being able to
enter in and out of different Realms and
access other Realms this is like hell's
own version of the bifrost from Asgard
that's really all it is the problem with
this is that it's guarded by Giants who
have been stationed there by hella of
course these Giants have basically
passed somewhere along the line but this
is their charge and so malekith being as
capable as he is basically Slaughters
them all and yet again the Priestess of
hella comes to her and says malachith
and John shade are at the cosmic
waterways they're killing the Giants
they're vying to escape and again hella
doesn't really seem to take it seriously
she says hell is not a prison it is a
ring of Trials where great questions are
asked of those who find their way here
we do not have these answers yet how am
AI to make up my mind this Intruder have
his sins been weighed or has he yet to
commit them if he has been brought to
our Shores in a noble Pursuit does he
deserve to suffer then for all eternity
so again it's kind of a moral quandary
but do not mistake hella's intentions
here this is her just kind of musing and
even entertaining herself to a degree
her bigger scheme here is to find out
why these guys are here and that if
there's one of them she can use to
basically make herself an ally of and
then expand her sphere of influence it's
always her main goal it's always the
things she's shooting for and so what
ends up happening is that in musing to
herself in this way she presents herself
to Carnage now again Carnage would be a
fool to attack hella in her own realm
and in fact he doesn't right like she
pops up and she says I am hella mistress
and queen of this realm and I know and
see all who set their feet upon hell
snow I don't take kindly to the hell
bound seeking to escape before they paid
for their sins I might be able to help
you find what you seek and Carnage does
not attack her he doesn't taunt her he
literally says and what do I get in
return because it's a smart move if you
want to attack hella she would just
annihilate him on the spot and that
would basically be it and so jumping
back to John shade and malekith what
John starts to realize is that malakis
bloodlust right his desire for battle
along with his anger towards being
punished in this way and hell has just
kind of Taken hold that he just wants to
slaughter and kill everything within
this realm as fast as he possibly can
and even when Jon tries to reason with
him the response of malachith is I'm not
done here yet right like I'm not done
killing every single being that's here
even if I killed every occupant of this
realm a thousand times over it wouldn't
be enough and so where malachith and Jon
are basically arguing and bickering with
each other Carnage appears alongside
Helen now this is a really really
interesting Showdown and this is one of
the reasons why I love the Carnage story
right now because you get to see these
kind of conflicts and matchups that you
would normally never see in Marvel
Comics and it's so cool right seeing
Carnage allied with hella going after
malachith one of the most powerful Gods
out there in Marvel it's just something
that you don't see and even malakis
himself does not take harness seriously
he goes as far as to say like I'm aware
of what you are right you're a Symbian
I've used you or at least your kind in
the war of Realm specifically he's
talking about Venom but the response of
Carnage is you faced off against
versions of me or things similar to me
but you've never actually fought me and
that's what's so cool is because what it
shows is just how powerful Carnage is
this story arc is a massive boost in the
power that Carnage has because under any
normal circumstance Carnage would not be
able to go toe-to-toe with malakis but
whether it's because of the fact that he
absorbed the power of some of the
hellhounds the power that he's made
basically gained over the course of the
story or the fact that Ram V the guy
who's writing the story is just moving
the power of Carnage up whatever the
motivation is this guy goes toe-to-toe
with malakith and then overpowers him
and when he does he just starts like
pumping this kind of substance into
malachith now what's actually going on
here is this less Carnage putting
something in malakis and more him
siphoning something out and that's
what's cool is because while John shade
is watching all of this he sees Kenneth
and realizes Kenneth making a deal with
Carnage is what set all this in Motion
in the first place so he initially tries
to kill Kenneth now of course the forces
of hella stop him and literally she says
this guy Kenneth is under my protection
which is part of the deal that I struck
with Carnage but you John shade are not
supposed to be here your time is not
come and you've committed no sins that
would bring you here in the first place
so unless you want to end up here back
off right so it's kind of hella doing
him a bit of a favor which is is sort of
a really interesting moment here but
what ends up happening is that even when
the questions asked by John shade of
hella do you know what Carnage is trying
to do do you know where all of this
leads her response is I have no idea
what he's doing but I have some idea of
where he's going some idea of what it is
that he's about to do and by the gods I
do love a good apocalypse and so here's
the beauty of all of this this is this
kind of mind-blowing ending right what
Carnage did the whole reason he went
after malakith in the first place is
because malekith was touched by the
Venom symbiote in the war of Realms
which means a piece of the Codex is Left
Behind now remember a codex is what's
left inside of a person whenever they
are bonded to a Symbian it's basically a
door when he had removed this codex from
from malakis he got a piece of the Venom
symbiote now why does that matter
because remember in the Venom Comics
Eddie Brock is out there in the
Multiverse not only that he's contending
with these astronomically powerful
versions of themselves and so what this
means is that with Carnage now in
possession of the Venom symbiote he can
find the Venom symbiote he can kill the
Venom symbiote and attain the symbiote's
power if that happens Carnage Takes Over
Control of every symbiote across not
just the universe but the Multiverse
because remember Eddie Brock is
currently the king in Black the original
King in Black was null null created
every symbiote across the Multiverse
with Eddie Brock replacing him Eddie now
does the same but if Carnage can access
the Venom symbiote kill Eddie and then
take over Carnage now becomes the new
null the Symbiote God of Marvel Comics
it's nuts if that happens everybody dies
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace
thank you